and you're tremendously confident
am i yeah you seem to be yeah people
tell me that
yeah
no i think you'd have to be to do this
kind of work yeah i guess so in a sense
huh never really thought of it like that
yeah i guess i am confident
all right mason yo mason uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally um
well i was uh
i was born in memphis tennessee
and uh
i think right around three or four i
went to
we moved to indiana so i grew up in the
midwest so indiana
born in memphis but grew up in indiana
got it and what was your childhood like
you had both your folks yeah well up
until about
seven years old my biological father
passed away uh unfortunately it happens
he got in a uh he got in a car accident
and uh uh he passed away
and uh
um
i think from there there was some
mixed emotions within the household with
my mom she's she's she's an awesome
person i don't have anything bad to say
about her but we didn't get along at
that point so we we had a falling out so
i was actually uh
i got adopted basically by my really
good friends
parents
so so your mom actually lost you
in a sense i guess absolutely i have
more of a bond with
um
with my adopted family than i ever did
with my biological mom but your mom lost
you i mean there's no drugs involved or
anything like that
as far as myself with your mom oh no no
with her no that's what i'm saying
absolutely not she i don't i don't know
what it was she uh she's not an
alcoholic she's not a drug user she's
just uh what's the best way
that everyone's cut out to be apparent
you know right or sits or like just like
that what did my older brother spencer
say uh
does remind you of like that really the
stern
southern
you know don't put up with no crap yes
ma'am no ma'am kind of girl so it's you
know it's generation gaps bro but your
childhood with the
family that my childhood was great
besides that little that that little
messing up i mean i had a great
childhood i grew up in new palace in
indiana a great little suburb of
indianapolis
great school system i had great friends
great neighborhood i mean it i i have
no hang-ups about my childhood it was it
was actually really great that's great
and uh you went through high school yeah
went all the way through high school in
the same town so i started in preschool
in new palestine and i graduated from
well technically i graduated from
greenfield central because i got a
little bit of trouble towards the end of
high school i got in like a little fight
but because i was 18
and i think they're going to try to
expel me i just i dropped out
but you could when you're 18 there was
something where you could drop out but
you were allowed to enroll in any other
school in the county because i was an
adult so i just dropped out of new pal
before they could expel me and just
enrolled in greenfield and i graduated
greenfield i walked down the aisle and
in blue and blue and gold baby what kind
of kid are you in high school uh more
like a skater alternative punk
uh rock and roll
skater guy yeah 100 and then uh after
after school you did what
let's see here after high school a lot
of partying a lot of rock and roll i uh
uh got into rock and roll bands big time
um
uh and a lot of partying a lot of my uh
i didn't go to a university at all but a
lot of my friends that i grew up you
know went to like purdue iu ball state
isu
um and so i spent a lot of time after
high school playing beer pong
and hanging out at fraternity houses and
all that kind of stuff so it was again
after high school just it was just
living one day at a time just having a
really good time so
up until about 21
is when i got into
dancing per se how did you get started
with that well i actually
tried to get started before that i had a
fake id that i
had found
it didn't really even look like me but
uh i just i wanted to get out there and
and dance
and so i went to go try out at this uh
it was a gay bar downtown called the uh
the unicorn
and uh
first off i would just like to say i
appreciate all walks of life and i love
everybody in a sense on your lifestyle
choices but you have to understand at
this time i'm a 19 year old kid
that grew up in little indiana and i
remember walking into that gay bar and
the first thing i saw was like
like when you walk into the right there
was a big shower and this guy was just
butt ass naked just going to town with
the shower on them and there was gay
porn on the tv it it
it just took it took me by surprise you
know so i
i i didn't get the i didn't get the
courage are you gay mustered up uh i
don't think so the reason why i say that
is i'm not attracted to the metal figure
but um in my i think transsexuals and
ts's are very beautiful so uh
some are incredibly beautiful incredibly
beautiful so like there's a there's a
fine line there you have some people
tell you that hey man you're bisexual
because you know they have something
they call a girl [ __ ] or whatever you
want to call it again i'm not trying to
sound but
you either
are on one side or the other and i don't
if you want to call me bisexual great
i'll take it if you want to call me
straight i'll take it i i could give a
[ __ ] about labeling so back to the club
you walk into this club yeah this took
me it just it took me off guard it 100
took me off guard and it not to say it
did it's kind of scared me out i
i took a break and i just decided it
wasn't and it wasn't until
after i was 21
um i had found out there was this place
called pt's which was a a strip club at
titty bar in indiana um on the east side
of indianapolis off pendleton pike and
uh on saturday nights they would do a
mail review
and uh
that's where i got my start stripping i
wouldn't try it out there uh the guy who
got me my start was running the crew his
name was tommy he was a a cool guy
called uh uh
crew of guys i remember when i first
came in and this was more my vibe i mean
it was it wasn't so explicit right away
you know just
you know it gets to that eventually but
you know but when i first walked in here
it's just a really nice chill vibe you
know because it's a strip it's a it's a
strip club there's all kind of mixes of
people in there and then he goes if you
want to come for a saturday and just
watch how we do our show
um
you can come watch and get some ideas
and i said yeah no problem and i watched
i went that saturday night and i watched
about one song
and i said bro put me up
he goes are you sure i said bro put me
up i had already had my chaps in my
cowboy hat like i'd come ready to go and
i just
just fed off the energy and that in that
situation you'd be on a circle stage
and they just had the chairs around the
circle you know so like they would
you know that funny strip club voice
where it's uh and to the center stage we
have porsha
and then two and four the ladies in the
back and at that time i i wasn't mason
yet they i had they come up with
something off the spot i was going by
sebastian so he would go and for the
ladies in the back we have sebastian i
always thought that was [ __ ]
hilarious
so i got into that and then um i wanted
to do it more
because that was only on saturday nights
so i already have gotten i would ease
into it more and kind of got a feel on
how to work the clubs and stuff and so
then i went back to that unicorn place
that was kind of a little too much too
quick and i eased right into that and i
was i was stripping at
um i was stripping at pt's on saturday
nights and i was tripping at the unicorn
wednesday thursday friday and every and
every other sunday i take a sunday off
just to take it off but that was a
really
that was a really fun place to work
so your personality kind of
made this easy for you 100 percent like
some people like i could never ever do
this yeah
i think those people that say that maybe
put too much
uh
capital in
their actual moves and stuff rather than
your personality you know if you could
just be open and just start talking to
people you'd be amazed how many people
are just happy to have some i mean
you've got a lot of men that go to strip
clubs just happy to have some hot chicks
on his lap talking to him you know
there's plenty of that going there i i i
had plenty of
guys would come in there and they'd pay
me just to sit there
and talk to him some of them would pay
me to to like
be mean to him you know i always felt
kind of weird about that because it was
funny but this one guy would come in and
want me to degrade him
call him a [ __ ] and a gay yeah i know
right weird right but he would he he
would
he would literally he would be in the
corner and i would be doing it being
saying degrading things i just i don't
really want to repeat because i don't
it's you know what i'm saying but at
that time this is a [ __ ] true story
man he would pay me to grade him and
like i'd be sitting there degrading him
and he just he always had a stack of 20s
and he would just sit there 20
wait you know five minutes 20 wait five
minutes and i knew when he was there it
was great and girls will understand this
girls know when they're like when they
see that person i don't have to work
tonight
i'm going to go up on stage once and i'm
going to go back there and hang out with
him for
four hours or however long he's here i'm
going to make 5 600
you know and and
that's good money if you can pull down
500 a day i don't care who you are it's
good money
and so that led to what you eventually
moved to vegas kind of maya so back to
where like um
uh have you been married no no married
no kids uh back to where i was here i
was adopted um i will be uh i'll be 37
next month so september i'll be 37.
so and you're tremendously confident
am i yeah you seem to be yeah people
tell me that yeah
no i think you'd have to be to do this
kind of work yeah i guess so in a sense
huh never really thought of it like that
yeah i guess i am confident but my that
family that had adopted me you know
they're always very supportive of of
everything i've done and uh steve
which is my adopted father um was
telling me about this uh competition um
it's about an hour south of chicago in
roseland indiana it's technically in
indiana but it's an out it's no one's
heard of roseland indiana so it's a
place that's an hour south of chicago in
indiana called uh the ponderosa sun club
and they do a thing called nap which is
nudes uh poppin and it's a
it's mainly catered towards the women
and like you know when you like you go
to strip clubs and you'll see like the
billboard of like the featured dancers
so this is this is like the kind of
competitions those girls go to compete
for those titles so they can say that
they're this or they're that and they're
this
and again you know it's mainly you know
catered towards the women but they have
a
men's thing a competition so i entered
it um and my whole family showed up i'm
butt ass neck and competing i got all
four of my brothers my dad they're all
cheering me on you know i get called up
um i want some awards to be naked in
front of your family i didn't care see
at that point i've already been
stripping i didn't care it got
i was
i got really comfortable real quick it
didn't bother me you know i'm not i'm
not i know i'm not king kong bundy or
nothing but i'm also not short either so
i mean i'll let it hang i'm not ashamed
but yeah i and uh uh that's that's
something that happened every year but
from that first year when i won was it
opened up a lot of doors for me because
my dad at the time was already coming
out here he had bought at hot springs
and they're in california and he was
already setting up out here in vegas so
i won that competition i got some job
offers and i came straight out here and
went straight to work so and i haven't
looked back since and it's just been
it's been an amazing it's been an
amazing career i mean at this point it's
a career
and now you're specializing in more like
private engagements right i always
especially so when i'm when i first
moved to vegas
um
i was here for about six months before i
started working for the agency that i'm
with now i don't know why i point like
he's right there but like while working
for the agency that i do now um i work
there's there's a uh uh there used to be
a bar on the strip here called crave it
was k-r-a-v-e and it was where planet
hollywood and all that used to be it's
it's long gone now but uh it was a gay
bar but they had it wasn't a strip club
it was just like you know you go to bars
and have the go-go dancers so i got
started there
and i got fired after
i don't know i was in and out they
told me i was a i got laughed at i came
out here got laughed at i was like all
right [ __ ] so then i was like all right
there's this this guy at the unicorn had
told me about this other place piranha
so i just went to piranha and i just
they
i love that place because
they took me in and it was go go dancing
and then because i'm just a hustler i
consider myself a hustler and you could
you could dance
for 30 minutes and take a break for 30
minutes or you could dance for 30
minutes and go sell shots for 30 minutes
so i just did both so i was just killing
it so i went to the the gay clubs and
then
uh uh during that time i'd been filling
out online applications for the private
stuff and then i got the call back from
sin city strippers and i've been dancing
for sin city strippers for about
about 14 years
so you're doing a private
a private engagement where you're
stripping for yeah
it could be a uh like a birthday party
or yeah birthday party bachelorette
divorce or just a party mother's day
parties uh retirement parties um hospice
partners and you'll show up like dressed
like a however they want i got a i got
it all i got firefighter cowboy cop uh
room service doctor i mean all kinds
i've even shown up as a
excuse excuse me i've even shown up as a
as a clown i've shown up as uh i'm going
to say it wrong cause i don't watch the
[ __ ] show but i think his name is
legolas from the lord of the rings i've
showed up as that the bow and arrow guy
i've showed up as him one of the most
recent ones i did that i thought was
[ __ ] hilarious
uh was i showed up as colombo i didn't
know people right isn't that crazy
so when you go to these private parties
you'll take your clothes off how naked
do you get with all the pins like uh
just the the regular show up is i just i
strip i mean every stripper is a little
bit different but most of the guys will
strip down to uh i ship down to like
some nice briefs or some nice box of
reefs like some nice you know armani or
calvin klein just a nice a nice name
brand that people can recognize um and
then uh you can usually when you get
hired for these things um it's always
usually a surprise for like the birthday
person
the person who it's for so you always
meet with like a friend or two before
they either come down in the lobby and
meet you meet them out in the hallway to
go over things collect the walk-in fee
all that good stuff um and you just and
then you'll try to sell it to them there
you'll say for an extra
duh we'll go fully nude and we call the
fully nude show fire nice
so uh sometimes they go for it and it's
funny because sometimes they don't and
then you'll you'll be doing such a good
job in the party they'll run up to you
and slide you the money go yeah we want
it we want it you know so it just
depends what they want some girls want
to have a wild fun time and some girls
literally just want to be teased and
just laugh i mean
all walks of life you know what is it
that women want like you go to a strip
club for men
and the guys just want the women i know
for a fact
from years of doing this i've done
thousands of these [ __ ] parties
thousands you gotta yeah i've been doing
private parties every weekend every
weekend since 2007.
i've buried taking very few weekends
office when i go on vacation and
probably have an interesting perspective
on what women yes a nice content yeah
and they what women respond to in my
situation is they want to have fun and i
mean want to have fun it doesn't they're
not their [ __ ] aren't sopping wet and
they're not lining up to suck my [ __ ]
although that has happened but for the
most part they just the person that
they're doing it for they want them to
feel embarrassed they all laugh they all
get to throw the ones at you and then we
have a set of moves that we do where we
pick them up and we flip them around and
we do all kinds of stuff we you know
it's just you you make them laugh and
you make them feel like they're having
like a good time and if you do that
you've done your job
it's probably a much healthier attitude
towards
the male female interaction than what
men have with with female pressure
that's what i tell girls too because
girls sometimes they'll ask me what i
make and uh which i'm not going to
discuss here but they'll ask me what i
make sometimes and
i'll give them a ballpark and they'll
they'll their immediate reaction is
always is always i i need to be a
stripper you know and i tell them with
just what you just said so you know
there's a big difference between what
i'm doing and what you have to do
like i'm coming in here
dancing for a bunch of hot chicks
getting paid looking cool laughing
having a good time flipping you guys
around i mean there's not much
like i tell them the same thing it's not
like you girls are lined up to suck my
[ __ ] i mean that very rarely happens man
and when that happens you're getting
that kind of group of girls and you
don't walk out of the room feeling used
and degraded no oh [ __ ] no i walk and
feel like a stud right i'm sorry i walk
in feeling like a stud and i walk out i
feel like a stuff where's a woman very
often might feel that yeah and i tell
them that because when you when the
girls and the girls make about triple
what i make i mean girls do hella good
but they they're coming here and you're
they want to see your [ __ ] they want to
see your ass they want to see your
titties they want to touch you you're
going to be grinding on guys you're
going to be grinding on guys boners i
mean i know as weird as that sounds
that's what you're doing so
i don't want to call it degrading
because to me
if a girl is comfortable with her life
choices and she wants to have fun it's
not degrading but if you feel like it's
bothering you you shouldn't do it
yeah 100
yeah it takes a very
thick skin
for a woman it depends how you look at
it again maybe thick skin for someone
who shouldn't be in the business in the
first place but there's girls out there
who have no business being in
relationships just like there's some
guys that don't and they like to have
fun
and you can you can totally tell that
some in in a in a positive sense being
degraded of them a little bit is a
turn-on
it's i mean i've just seen so much of it
man i just i've seen so much the
attitude and the energy i just
i know what i'm talking about
the scenario that you're describing at
that gay club in indiana where the guy
wanted to be
degraded yeah he was paying you to do
there's a real and with with women you'd
never find that do you
women oh oh yeah right like women want
to pay me to be degraded no absolutely
not women pay me to come in and make
sure i let them know that i would not be
here if it wasn't for you girls and this
party's about you it's not about me so
when you hire me i'm going to make sure
i do the best possible job that i can to
make sure you and your friend have a
great time or friends with women it's
just about having a good time yeah i
come in i got a whatever outfit you want
the most popular one lately has been
cowboy and firefighter um i have a music
player that has disco lights on the
bluetooth and everything we set up the
room and it's a [ __ ] we run it like a
club so doing this kind of work for you
and you've done it for a long time
almost 15 years you don't you don't get
depressed or
feeling like
quite the opposite there's i know we're
covered up now but there's plenty of
times like i just did a party
it was two
it was either last second they'll run
together it was either last saturday or
the saturday no it was two saturdays ago
100
and it was a 11 a.m party and it was for
a 21st birthday and the moms hired me uh
and it was at the tower suites which
those of you don't know what it is
that's the encore has the encore but
then there's also the encore tower
sweets which is just another bomb side
of the encore and they had the two-story
suite
so uh i i you know you go on these it's
like it does the quite opposite i get to
go to the coolest i've been in the
thirty thousand dollar night uh sweet at
caesar's palace i've been to the
presidential suite at the mandalay bay
i've been to all of them i remember
walking down the hallway when i first uh
i was at the palazzo venetian walking
through the hallway to one of my first
big parties there passing leonardo
dicaprio and some of his homies in the
in the uh in the hallway i remember
being at the aria and i'm like a big fan
of the office i ran right into oscar the
guy in the office and him and kevin were
there he said come have a beer and i was
like i gotta go it was cool to say to
him like but i gotta go strip and i
pointed over and there's a hot blonde
waving at me he's like go get him you
know so it's just the it's it's the
every little seems like experience is
just
uh it's uplifting but there's always
exception to that you can be not
degraded but you'll go into parties
where they shouldn't have gotten a
stripper or they're too freaked out or
they don't want to be touched or they
don't want to do this and do that and
it's like well if you're going to have
that kind of attitude i mean you just
you're probably better off doing
something else for the girl rather than
getting a stripper
it's politely put
we get a call at the office and are you
aware what a dominatrix is yes so it's
when i first moved here so a dominatrix
calls us
and she's looking for email stripper
and she's looking for a mouse stripper
because a client of hers
and this was here at mandalay bay this
was at one of the nice presidential
suites at manola bay she had a client
that wasn't i mean obviously no names i
don't even think i remember the guy's
name anyway she had a client that was
extremely wealthy but like to dress like
a woman
and be degraded
and
he wanted to have a mock bachelorette
party you follow me kind of so
he calls us dominatrix to set it all up
so he the dominatrix
calls our company
and she has a bunch of her friends there
just to act like the girls in the group
you know so
of course i take it i'm gonna go knock
this out i'll never forget walking in
that suite
and i'm not knowing what kind of you
know
you're gonna see and this this this
gentleman that liked the cross dress
which is totally fine i remember him
looking just like princess diana i'll
never forget that
i'll never forget that like the the hair
the the pearls the nice like she was
business out and they i remember i was
told to kiss the ring and be really
proper dude i'm a paid actor i've always
i'm a hustler and paid actor this is
your party as as long as i'm not doing
anything in my mind that i feel like i
don't want to do which i will openly say
in two seconds uh i'm good with it so
i'll kiss a ring let's go
so
it starts with that i go and do my whole
thing and they had this
this table kitchen table kinda with the
chairs on the sides and like the big
chairs on the end you know and i
remember up top was the
the mirrored ceiling
and he was in the nice she sorry she was
in a nice big chair on the end and all
her friends were there and i remember
dancing on the table right and that kid
dancing they paid for the full nude show
i'm fully nude and i'll never forget
as a party progressed on i'm up on the
table and i noticed the party's kind of
splitting up a little bit and
i looked over to the right
and this guy's just getting plowed in
the ass by a big black strap-on from the
dominatrix and i'm dancing on this table
and i'm looking over at this this uh
this this person getting plowed
by a big black strap born by dominatrix
and i had i had been in vegas maybe a
year and i i thought like the wizard of
oz like you're not in kansas anymore
like i'm i'm not in indiana anymore you
know and uh that's that was a 100 true
story and it's all about perspective and
that's
how i perceived it people are
interesting aren't they
there's all walks of life out there i've
done parties with uh one another
favorite parties i've done was uh it's
happened on two occasions uh persian
women [ __ ] beautiful women persians
are beautiful and i don't know if
they're suppressed by their culture but
it seems like when they just get
together with no guys they get wild man
they're hot and they're beautiful
you know there's a i won't i'll really
say they're the most beautiful women but
anyway with that said
i'm doing these persian parties and this
one in particular uh turns into a damn
near orgy uh
i remember being badass naked and girls
they were they were wrapping hundred
dollar bills around my [ __ ] and jerking
me off with it and they were naked and
having a good time and i remember laying
there basically borderline getting
ravaged and raged by all these hot
person women and i think i made eight or
nine hundred dollars that night it's
just ridiculous i had another one a few
months later not the 100 bills but
persians it was another wild party uh i
mean i could go on for days man like
i mean it's just another and he knows
what i'll see this weekend
i mean i never know what the [ __ ] i'm
walking into but i know that i'm gonna
be life of the party and i know that
you're gonna have a great time if you
hire me so all right mason thank you so
much for sharing your stories no 100 i'd
like to come back any time because i i
feel like we uh we barely scrape the
surface because i i literally have i'm
in the middle of doing a book but i
literally have
i i i have so many more stories like
that like that real quick i look on this
the time where i did a gay but it was it
was a bunch of gay guys and they had a
girlfriend and they wanted to get a
stripper for their girlfriend it was her
birthday party and they had it catered
and everything and i remember it being
all guys and just her so i'm dancing she
was a hot girl too and uh they're all
like going pull her tits out you know
pull her and they're we're circled while
i'm dancing and she's in a chair and
we're in a circle and they're going
they're drinking partying and i saw i
look at her i always ask like is it okay
and she's like yeah yeah yeah
and she's hot she pulls my i'm like oh
man so like i start i start getting hard
you know and uh they're like pulls
caught they're starting you know they're
yelling pull this [ __ ] out i was like i
just did the whole look like you know if
you when she pulled it out and they're
going sucky
and i was like and before i know it this
girl is just blowing me right she's just
going at it feels so good and i'm gonna
come bro like it's so good i'm actually
gonna [ __ ] blow my load and i have
all these guys around and when i came i
came all over her tits and i got a
standing ovation from everybody in that
[ __ ] room
what do you like about vegas you love it
here love it i'll be here um i got a
great support system here um i have a
great career here um uh i have uh family
friends uh i just i i am i'm here
i live on the strip i've lived on the
strip for about six or seven years now
um
i
i'm not married no kids uh right now i'm
currently taking care of a shout out to
joe i'm taking care of my 94 year old
grandpa right now so he just turned 94
last wednesday so happy happy belated to
joe that's nice of you yeah no man it's
it's this the way life works you got
family you got nothing so uh uh i'm
taking care of him we're we're the we're
the odd couple
i was making him breakfast i made him
breakfast and coffee this morning before
i headed over here and what's uh what
would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
uh
the universe will always give you things
and it can't always
decipher
what's good and bad so stay positive
always stay positive think of positive
things be pessimistic be positive the
glass is half full and there's no room
for negativity
i mean if i've just got to be that's
great about it that's seriously be
positive be nice to people and uh
charlie murphy had a saying that i
really really like is like you should go
out and respect everybody man just
respect everybody everyone has that
saying growing up you've got to earn my
respect
respect everybody
what you allow people to earn if you
want is your disrespect and once you're
in a disrespect you don't throw negative
energy you just
and go into being positive so that would
be it that's great 100.
you